[Musique]
il
m
[Musique]
moi ça va c'est arrive souvent qu'on
t'offre en cadeau à des gens
très deux fois par semaine a quand même
ce qui en général
cd tout en fait je travaille beaucoup
pour des clubs des clubs et pas les
petits clubs plutôt déclame c'est
c'est bien sinon c'est des femmes qu un
petit peu d'argent qu'ils offrent à
leurs marines pdg maman oui
heureusement certains de faire une fille
comme toi leurs maris pdg poubelles font
ça
je sais la fontasse mme oui je maman je
suis pdg j'avais ma femme mais qu'est ce
qui se passe en général
jamais chez les gens c'est la surprise
pour l'homme
qu'est ce que tu fais et
je mets ma musique que j'ai commencé à
danser mon script et puis après je
repars débat qui demandent de rester une
fois oui causé des soirées universal je
reste je bois un verre avec les gens je
discute un peu je danse et puis après je
repars sur part tout seul combien de
fois pour être sur 10
le temps même si le pdg est super beau
super riches et sa femme super sympa
c'est le spectacle uniquement
moi je vais t'offrir un copain très
sympa que j'adore j'espère que tu lui
plaira surtout le père à bord
c'est qui philippe proteau il s'appelle
c'est un ami à moi depuis très longtemps
vient de faire une émission de
télévision il s'appelle rayons x et pour
le féliciter le fait un très bon sujet
pour le féliciter pour le remercier il a
droit à sa maintenance et bien
un cadeau
mais comment tu as été amenés à faire ça
[Musique]
je travaillais en italie comme coco girl
et puis
des gens m'ont proposé des gens j'ai
rencontré mon pour vous c'est fait ça en
boîte
j'ai accepté et puis après on m'a
demandé si j'acceptais de pub pour des
privés ouais j'ai accepté aussi c'est
une agence que gère ça il ya dix agences
qui est qui s'occupent de moi et je
travaille aussi tout seul en direct les
gens qui ont un numéro qu'est ce qui se
passe
oui ouais mon char et ouais ça reste
très correct oui oui c'est mental et à
quel âge tu es parti faire la coupure en
italie 18 ans à 18 ans et pourquoi pas
ce que j'aimais déjà le spectacle était
saisi par le démon du spectacle oui
j'aime bien
qu'est ce tu faisais avant 18 ans je
fais des photos et puis
je participe à des concours de miss
c'est tout tu arrêtes tes études à ces
jeunes filles un nom de 20 ans avant amy
malgré les concours de miss et continuer
continuer tes études tu as tu dis quoi
et l'homme c'est trop cher
tu parles beaucoup de langues étrangères
je n'ai pas ainsi non si tu vas à quoi
l'on sérieux
anglais espagnol russe italiana
je passais pas mal de temps en allemagne
de l'est donc je le vends d'origine non
non ma famille vient du danemark mais
j'ai passé pas mal de temps berlin et
puis après en italie après hollande et
puis voilà l'appareil peut quand même
temps que je travaille à paris
un an et demi mais ça marche bien oui
pour l'instant c'est oui des fois ça
tourne mal quand on est offerte comme ça
pour un strip tease dans une soirée ya
des fois des moments où c'est un peu
bizarre
ah non ça va parce que des fois la femme
du pdg d'apple et puis quand tu arrives
en fait je voyais trois mecs qui
t'attendait pas de femmes de pdg ou un
truc comme ça s'arrête
oui tout le temps mais ça c'est pas
grave je sais pas de spectacle c'est
clair y'a pas défaut c'est un peu
dangereux quand même ça non t'as pas
peur non c'est moi de savoir gérer
ouais mais non intentionnelle à tes yeux
pour défendre
oui mes griffes ça marche bien le pire
truc et soirée c'est quoi
un truc le plus dur quand même plus dur
c'est
un patron de bois qui voulait pas mais
c'est à partir
coincé 15 km un accord sans quoi que je
que j'avais les jambes un portable c'est
moi je le dis j'ai appelé la police tout
simplement
ouais ça va calmer alors vous êtes un
portable
oui
[Musique]
oh
voir
gk
ça
[Musique]
ouah
j'ouvre les yeux cette enquête de
mourinho à un merci thierry voilà il est
beau il est beau des cadeaux h prière et
brunes en général mais elle est
tellement jolie
merci savane homme je peux t'offrir les
fleurs sa manade touche mais c'est mieux
voilà donc philippe c'est mon cadeau
c'est pour l'australie voilà c'est parce
que tout ce que tu as fait en rayons x
je vais te faire un beau cadeau c'est
gentil et les magnifiques à d'abord là
et tu sais que dans dix secondes
australie je n'ai pas croisé mais comme
ça vous acceptez bout du mans et un bar
en continu comm sa non j'avais de la vie
là bas c'est impossible
moi j'ai pas été à sydney mais dans
l'endroit où j'étais savannah est ce que
tu te
déshabillerait en dansant pour philippe
qui est ce que tu feras un script et
je sais pas mais oui j'accepte je la
trouvais ça mais bien ça à numéroter les
fans mon pote ça plus le pétard que
c'est en train de se rouler au-dessus de
5% d'audience on a droit à ça j'ai fait
ça me sens aimé un indice etc sur le cac
qui compte plus que 5 % dassa imagine
voyez ce qui se tape mais combien voyage
à boyet lui fait dix-huit donc tu
imagines il a quatre fois sa part moi
c'est une façon de récompenser les
animateurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parfait je savais en âge que féliciter
oui
l un des défauts net appelle le soir tu
es chez toi y'a rien à la télé
jamais ses mots le programme atterri sur
moi meurtre dès qu'un numéro de savannah
tu trouves les programmes bien été
laissé mais à mon avis si on avait 17
ans ryo rixe avait beaucoup plus vrai
t'es con mais comme là bas il fallait
faire la tribu les strip teaseuses à
domicile allociné ne s'arrête plus
jamais
[Musique]
merci à toi les publics elle mais ça me
regarde
[Musique]
la france a pris trois ans de retard
bonjour on va dire que c'est la plus
belle boulanger de parigots banale elle
est pas mal et c'est la pub en hausse et
une pomme une foire vous avez 60 kw et
donne
il reste cuba tant pis éléments
apparaissent comme un ermite au dessus
alors là bien sûr bien venir faire une
strip teaseuse
il ne s'est pas saisie saillir il ne
savait pas on a débarqué chez les mecs
la sottise et je crois même qu'il la
raccompagnait il arrive à l'inconvénient
de moi c'est tout finito c'est vrai que
c'est beau ici en juillet 1896 à la
sentant alma vance entend cette année et
c'est un truc que vous vous devez de
père en fils dans la finlande en moi ça
fait 19 ans que celui-là ces deux
spécialités du sud ouest alors oui c'est
pas plus cher en plus
bien fait merci beaucoup merci
mais bon pour l'instant philippe alors
fini je crois que ça y est la meilleure
main allez salut c'est heu bah katz à
moi je marque un petit prend la caf le
modèle la boulangère exact ce modèle de
jéhovah cats et la boulangère qu'est ce
qu'elle est
[Musique]
mais
tu vois là
[Musique]
tu veux qu'on monte je vois bien comme
moi allez allez on va faire que ça mais
à l'entente de chermiti si je ne sais
pas c'est un assez joli super d'aller là
bas c'est toujours la même chose sous le
toit toutes les motos aujourd'hui c'est
un petit peu j'en refais au paris-dakar
faux biker et comme ça tous les mecs qui
sont dessus et ressemblent à des clones
c'est catastrophique et nous on s'est
dit quand même ça serait bien qu'ils
aient une moto tu vois un peu pour les
gens normaux tu vois qu'ils sont pas
forcés de sa fille ivre de s'affubler
hells angels et donc l'idée c'est de
revenir comme d'ailleurs dans tout le
monde travaille mais revenir vers le
minimum et la simplicité c'est à dire
une moto c'est un moteur roue et après
le minimum de choses autour parce
qu'aujourd'hui je me geagea une grosse
moto japonaise pour faire de la pop non
les palabres j'espère mais dans un mur
pour faire de la route que j'ai mis dans
un mur
il y à il ya trois semaines une moto qui
coûte 42 mille francs public tu la mets
dans un mur ça coûte 60 mille francs de
réparation des moyens plastiques grâce
et comment tu veux que les jeunes gens
puissent se déplacer avec ce véhicule
intelligent pour la voiture non sa
tournée quand on se trompe quand on se
trompe et bien où on le met dans le dans
le mur d'ailleurs que ça ne tourne pas
avec ma fille a mis sa son scooter deux
ans donc ça ne tourne party by l'enlever
le sco va bien canadien a maintenant 17
à saint geniez personnes je reviens chez
ses environs ça fait 20 ans et je te
connais maintenant que je t'ai vu
arriver à façade mondino vachement bien
utile quand même plus
[Musique]
chaque étage une spécialité des comprend
bombes ont fait les motos il se
normaliserait dit c'est à toi je dis pas
ce qu'il ya dans les étages on ne peut
pas dire que ce sont les coordonnées je
sais quand on reste aussi mois ci sont
évidemment de ce soir là c'est beau
c'est beaucoup cédé vallauris fera là
c'est bien mais c'est traître
chaque petit les petits paysages dedans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]
mais cette maison là bas pourquoi finit
pas cette maison maison j'ai construit
un jour de folie qui est bien trop
grande qui est inutile mais là l'intérêt
est sur la scène est comme moi je suis
en plus à des choses drôles d'heure
quand on pense que cette maison n'a pas
le droit d'être autographié caché en
train de vous laisse il a filmé lorsque
chez moi je vais tranquille
donc là on va voir actes et aux taxis
vénitien et c'est très pratique
c'est louis évidemment c'est magnifique
c'est bien ce soit et moi je suis un
phoque ne rit pas mais je ne peux vivre
que sur l'eau et tout est maison j'ai
sont toujours toujours sur l'eau sur un
pied trop haut
oui beaucoup trop mou dessus mais je le
réduis arrêté de me soigner mais ça ça
par contre c'est une sorte dé formation
professionnelle à écouter ça a été ça
écoutez le micro viennent par là écouter
le son de sa écouter ça
[Musique]
style de robe c'est un bidon d'huile qui
est affiné comme ça pour faire des notes
imaginent la qualité à dimanche matin
j'étais en moto à dimanche d'hiver
harlem et c'est là où j'ai eu un flash
avec ça il y avait plein plein plein de
d'ouvriers de fer blanc très comme ça
une trentaine qui le dimanche à se
réunissaient qui avait sorti tout sur le
trottoir et quant à trente mecs qui
savent jouer de ça en même temps tu es
mais c'était émouvant émouvant parce
qu'il ya vraiment là pour s'amuser parce
que l'aja plus par m après j'ai mon
tambour cocher une thérapie par le bruit
on va bah oui finalement ouais je suis
relativement claire presque heureux la
maquette
j'ai pas ce qui va nous tomber sur la
tête c'est normal j'ai une fiancée
magnifique
j'attends un bébé je suis enceinte je
vais accoucher dans deux mois et ben
voilà quoi pourquoi ça ne répond pas aux
serres la première fois que je t'ai vue
continue à des excuses et des buts ont
utilisé les babouches et onctueuse à la
main dans la main je n'ai la main bleue
ça peut c'était cohérent
puis un jour tu es arrivé je me souviens
puis tu nous as dit que tu allais faire
un immeuble au japon je me suis dit ça y
est il a pété les plombs
ben oui il y en a quelques-uns près
enfin bon je suis plutôt sur la
réduction des activités parce que en
fait ça fait 20 ans que j'ai pas eu une
minute à moi que j'ai appelé linky doit
être qui est abominable qui date à peu
près comme le tien est bon là ça va ça
suffit tu vois maintenant je peux rien à
me prouver à moi-même mon ego et y est
tout est assez tranquille et en fait
maintenant ce que je voudrais m'arrêter
doit d'ici un an et me mettre en
disponibilité pour faire des choses plus
direct pour rendre service
moi je sais pas encore quoi mais je
pense que maintenant il ya vraiment une
urgence qui voie de devenir des vrais
citoyens et il faut le faire et pour ça
il faut libérer du temps et d'énergie de
l'intelligence j'en ai donc c'est raté
je ne sais pas tu es bien que je
m'occupe jamais chose comme si je
regardais l'imac est sorti on voit tout
ce que tu as fait depuis 20 ans ouais
bah ni cesser le travail de l'hystérique
c'est moi mon problème principal c est
en petit j'étais invisible et
la visite c'est à dire quant à 16 17 ans
dès que tu as quel et les filles tu vois
que tu aimerais bien draguer qui te
regardent pas qu'ils voient à travers
toi quand tu apportes potes à ce moment
là tu deviens très très mal et moi 16 18
ans tu vois que des pays mixs haut comme
ça dans ma chambre cacher et un jour
j'ai retrouvé le seul héritage que j'ai
que j'ai que j'avais eue c'est à dire la
créativité toit de nos pères et c'est
pour ça que l'idée c'est que c'était le
seul métier que je savais faire que j'ai
retrouvé est en fait comme la vie
l'homme invisible qu'on ne voit que
lorsqu'il met ses bandelettes
moi j'ai dû sécréter des créations qui
sont en fait tous les objets autour de
moi et en fait c'est ce que vous voyez
est ce qu en fait moi je suis rien et le
jour où je serai incapable de créer leur
disparaîtra au grand plaisir de certains
quand je t'ai connu alors tu annonces
était rien et tu arrives et des tutus
arrivée des indes
ouais tu m'avais parlé d'un endroit tu
sais que tu es comme nation c'est théo
cette traque amundi voilà c'est
incroyable que je m'en souvienne de moi
aussi mais à l'époque ça quelque chose
qui est indispensable dans la salle
c'est une obligation ces obligations
l'intérêt c'est que c'est très pénible
en fait de voyager comme ça c'est une
aventure parce que de voyage c'est pas
un voyage géographique c'est toujours un
voyage au finalement tu te retrouves en
face de toi même quand tu as perdu tout
et codes tous tes amis trop 4 à me
mentais à poil et là il ya il doit se
passer quelque chose et il faut le faire
c'est très très très dur
moi je me suis retrouvé plusieurs fois
sur le chambranle la fenêtre il en veut
aux touches sont pas en plus tu prends
plein de mauvais produits et damman et
donc ça tape ça t'arrange pas le moral
mais ça m'a donné comme une vision
globale des choses qui permet quand même
depuis de savoir toujours ce qui va se
passer et quand tu apprends qu'il ya
quand même 100 mille afghans qui sont
mortes escale à cannes afghans tu
comprends pourquoi quand il convient
quand tu que tu apprends qu'il ya un
conflit tu sais pourquoi
et ça ça par un minimum parce que le
problème en fait de beaucoup de pays
mais surtout d'éviter français le
nombrilisme
simplement qu'ils sont comme ça comme ça
comme ça avec une toute petite vision
des choses et au jour d'aujourd'hui
justement où il serait vital de changer
d'échelle puisqu'en fait on est en face
tu nos problèmes qu'on a ces jours ci
viennent pas d'un problème social de
grève ou de trucs comme ça mais viennent
principalement de la du déclin de
l'empiré occidental est et que personne
ne comprend que tout le monde continue à
boxer en disant non non il y aura
toujours on va contrer le chômage et
ainsi de suite on va se battre c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai la richesse
l'énergie l'intelligence est passé en
asie c'est prévu depuis longtemps
maintenant c'est fait donc maintenant la
portance est de savoir comment on va
gérer notre déclare on peut vivre
heureux dans un trio en déclin et à ce
moment là où le tueur la boxe tu fais de
l'aïkido tu te sers de la force comme ça
de lagdo l'agresseur pour le transporter
sur autre chose et tu dis dans ce cas là
ou qu'il y aura de plus en plus de
chômeurs qu'est ce qu'on va faire quand
il rate de 10 millions de gens qui vont
nourrir les autres c'est pas grave ça on
peut déjà se confond ce qu'on fait déjà
pendant ce cas-là important c'est de
garder l'honneur de ces gens là c'est ça
l'important est donc à plein plein plein
plein de problèmes mais bon je dis ça
doit toujours du champagne quand même
[Musique]
sur voir que c'est un phare ici quand
même incroyable
il manque que le feu au dessus c'est
quoi ce bois exotique la voix marc c'est
un bois qui sert à faire des bateaux
mais attendirent plus j'en ai aucune
idée
le baisser un peu la musique alors tu
vois ya des proto comme ça pourrait des
futures assises
donc les gens vont s'asseoir comme ça
ouais on est on en train de travailler
sur le sur l'idée de dire aux gens
travailler moins réfléchissez plus et
donc on lance dans quelques mois une
collection de lits de travail mais parce
que les mecs qui sont comme ça toute la
journée dans le bureau
ouais ils ont mangé au restaurant il
dort ghana on leur dit côté ok vous avez
envie de dormir après midi tout le monde
c'est votre bio rythme allait dormir 20
minutes et après réfléchissez et quand
vous vous levez levé vous n'ai plus
besoin de chaises travailler réellement
pensées servait à quelque chose et c'est
évident et pour les gens aussi qui qui
qui qui travaillent sur ordinateur
rester une journée assis normalement
c'est impossible donc où il faut des
positions comme ça où tu es extrêmement
mobiles tu vois que des réglages
en tous les sens là c'est un peu tôt
encore waller ou alors c'est pas celle
là évidemment ou alors on sort des
positions pour en fait il va être comme
ça
ouais comme sur une chaise longue à et
tu veux avoir l'ordinateur qui va être
de l'emploi comme ça tu vas voir ton
clavier comme ça
couloir et et tonton écran comme ça et
là évidemment tu peux vraiment être dans
le dans le meilleur de toi même parce
qu'en fait mon travail c'est pas de
faire des jolies choses
mon travail c'est de de rendre un vrai
service d'apporter du bonheur que les
gens soient au mieux et que les gens
s'inscrivent dans leur société dans leur
civilisation pour qu'ils servent à
quelque chose
quand on pense qu'à 90% des gens qui
font figuration de travail qu'on finira
son bureau ça de vrai désastre
c'est pas que je me fous du travail mais
ce cas là où on travaille on travaille
pas mission le fait qu'on fasse mais
ceci dit on tout ceci est en attendant
c'est une stratégie provisoire parce que
évidemment mon mon vieux rêve de
dématérialisation est en train d'arriver
et donc les vrais services sous cutanée
vont arriver très très très très très
très très bientôt maintenant qui font
que le type à être à poil au bord de
l'eau va avoir une idée et va dire bon
bah tiens si j'appelais machin pour
vérifier les données tient un peu de
calcul truc comme ça bon bah c'est
vraiment bien quoique j'en vois hélas le
mec surf ou dans l'autre avec toi c'est
bah oui c'est moi je suis un peu
bêtement une sorte d'abrutis moderne
enfin très très enfants je crois donc je
dis ce que tu veux c'est comme tuer
pendant ses mandats
fava pour aller ça va c'est pour revenir
moi je vais te dire j'ai pas de problème
parce que je vais à peu près cinq
minutes pour revenir dans leur sort
j'habite au dessus moi aussi j'habite au
dessus de mon bureau
merci bien donc un linguiste arx et par
philippe starck ce design au dos qui l'a
mise dans son bureau il travaille dans
sa chambre aucun problème je sais pas
pourquoi les gens pensent à trois heures
pour aller bosser et au-dessus temps de
travail comme le dirait blandel ça va ça
va très bien c'est bien sa première fois
que je viens ici à paris la tuque mort a
pu dire s'avère bien j'ai un bon chef
barman boucle à deux fois par jour si on
conseille de manger la seriat une carte
a qu'à regarder web asie moi je prends
la carte
je vais regarder vrai
allons-y
là les petits gris c'est bon ça j'ai pas
cité afin qu'ils soient si le nom de ma
récente well au sexe ouais pour moi ça
s'appelle comme ça
garantissent le voilà le parce que
c'était la rue ici s'appelait rue
napoléon chaix et je savais pas comment
rappeler le restaurant ouais alors je
demande à trois prochains mois 4
d'ailleurs beau et bio ou d'héricourt
this way
bon tout est bien celui qui se déclare
toujours innocent avait donné un coup de
poing à l'arrivée à dire y'a pas de
problème
ce sera un mois un mois et demi on
reviendra si c'est bien on le dira et
six étapes au fermoir d'indium agissait
seul en type amy tu veux appeler çà
comme enjeux liés au marché noir
ce mardi c'est marrant j'ai fait ce soir
au marché noir vialou qui me fait oui
c'est marrant mais tu auras pas les
juifs fera pas les résistantes au rap à
l'école la mère ça va il me reste rien
aujourd'hui bon toi tu as vraiment
avenue dans les tontons flingueurs tout
ça dans tous ces films qui n'a plus des
comme toi tu es c'était
c'est un thé un survivant de sa de cette
époque du cinéma d'un dinosaure bah
ouais écoute j'ai fait cette année c'est
le dixième anniversaire de la mort de
mon pote michel audiard gekko dans le
livre la 38 37 coureurs cyclistes et moi
j'étais
je suis devenu professionnel et l'huile
est devenu porteur de journaux on s'est
perdus pour se retrouver après et quand
cette année on a fait des interviews sur
le 10e anniversaire damas michel audiard
l'a d'ailleurs dit la tante place
sixième fois et au téléphone pour une
interview je n'y mets plus d'un tel 6e
l'étudiante faire dos j'en ai fait
quinze radios thématiques toi et alors
il m'a dit oui à la rédaction quand tu
dis faut faire un truc trouver un proche
de michel audiard
gabin est mort billets non d'alban est
mort car des morts albert simonin des
morts ventura est mort ils sont tous moi
ton carnaval c'est ainsi qu'il a 19 ans
77 avec ma table bonjour
et en même temps que vous ne l'avez lu
principauté relais 27 25 ans 27
j'ai décoré d'une médaille
génial et très simple et a pas
l'impression d'être un peu un monument
historique des fois si des fois oui je
m'en fous c'est comme si on a plein de
fois il ya une femme qui me dit est ce
que vous avez un
je suis dit 'je n'ai pas de modèle et
comédien en général au talonnage
moi j'ai pas de modèle dit
todor julien vous dire pourquoi si je
venais inflige faut aller voir le
commissaire lui dire quand vous montez
sur une enquête parce que je peux aller
avec vous jusqu'au moment où le
directeur maintenu
c'est pas avec moi tandis que là c'est
pas facile puisque je tue tout le temps
et alors j'ai dit alors la semaine
dernière
mes amis c'est un contraste un assassin
professionnel
et je me dis je vais aller avec toi tu
dis non je mets ça tout seul à l'alba
regardés curieusement on connaît la fin
j'ai dit si j'ai un modèle de lycée qui
tue charles vanel
oui pourquoi pas ce qu'il a fait son
dernier film à 97
voilà ici quand même il ya un peu
certains soirs dans la salle il ya quand
même un peu les gendarmes et des voleurs
oui bien sûr c'est un terrain neutre
ça arrive ça arrive parce que j'ai des
amis des deux côtés sa vie de retraité
chaque fois qu'on peut reprocher c'est
que c'est pas voir
[Musique]
ouais
je ne vois pas de père loose
je ne suis pas un nervi je trouve que ça
fait acte ou deux
et c'est pourquoi moi j'vous l'dit j'ai
l'air de ne pas avoir l'air mais avec
mon mp la pige à bb je suis un dur un
vrai un tatoué gelé pabbi manioc qu'est
ce qu'on y gagne
pour les tourner en moi ce faux pas mais
jouer gilles risquent-ils bagne faut
l'avouer j'ai bouffé du cannibale j'ai
même dit gérer des balles il en faut pas
que je m'emballe
j'ai discuté
cap des bataillons d'afrique je porte la
marque de fabrique
et voilà pour le pendre un dante à
présent durban bras
[Musique]
oui
nostalgie du belge thomas
on parle de toi car je me rends pas bien
compte agrandir la gamme s9 ségolène
film 9 ckoi sais c'est pas d'avis et la
raison c'est la raison tu vois c'est là
d'accord est question puisque les autres
pourquoi tu crois que tu as fait tant de
films ah je sais pas je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai fait un bon agent sa
brutale au maintien les deux tu faisais
avant d'avoir 19 ans avant d'avoir dit
non j'avais 18 ans je faisais déjà des
films vu que je fais des films depuis
que j'ai 9 ou 10 ans donc est ce que je
faisais avant d'avoir 9 10 ans mais
pourquoi on fait des films au top 10 des
parts en effet enfin un départ c'était
un truc d'hazard c'était mes parents qui
sont pass meetic avec des potes dont les
enfants c'est de la pub et un jour on
m'a présenté un casting et ça a marché
donc c'était un truc c'était forcément
pas de ma volonté canton à 4,56
retrouvait sur les pubs et puis c'était
en même temps un truc qui m'amusait
parce que c'est vrai que quand on est
petit quand on a dix mille personnes
autour de vous qui relie mignonne celle
là et tout c'est rigolo
et puis et puis en fait c'était un truc
qui me plaisait qui m'amusait et je suis
rentrée dans une école l'école du
spectacle où c'était fait pour ça avec
des mômes qui faisait vraiment sain mais
presque presque de contrainte ça c'était
un peu bizarre
et puis ça m'a plu et puis au début
c'était un jeu c'était marrant et toupie
quand quand j'ai eu 13 ans je faisais
un film de john mann esposito qui
s'appelait mina c'est là où je me suis
rendu compte que non seulement ça me
plaisait vraiment donc ça pouvait être
un métier mais comme je le disais comme
un métier c'est un côté vachement
contraignant à tous j'imaginais pas que
un truc que j'ai mais je pouvais
peut-être en faire mon métier je me suis
rendu et là ça y est j'ai eu la chance
d'enchaîner
non j'ai envie que ça continue
j'aimerais bien le site a fait tous ses
films ben t'as pas eu tout le temps à
l'école quand même d'après sa part toi
même ouais enfin si j'allais à l'école
quand même j'ai tant l'avons vraiment
court jusqu'à ma femme secondes et
ensuite je suis pas très bien dans ma
terminale par correspondance
ça existe et est studieuse non mais
j'étais genre assez je vivais sur les
acquis mais mais l'école en soit ça me
faisait chier parce que j'ai du mal à me
faire appeler par son nom de famille
j'ai du mal à ce qu'on dit si tu es toi
ou ouais donc c'est vrai que le rapport
maître élève s'est pas fait parce qu'il
mangeait plus mais en même temps je mets
bien l'école ça me faisait pas plus que
ça comme dans le film tu dis que tu es
en salle donc tu as lens que mais
s'était jamais arrivé encore n'ont
jamais j'aurais pu j'aurais pu en france
à terme faire avorter mais non c'était
un état que je connaissais pas con tu
étais enceinte tu te faire avorter
je sais pas si j'étais un simple contre
mon gré si j'étais si je me retrouvais
un club parce qu'on cherche a été violée
oui parce que gênant c'est finalement
sam de tangible tu te ferait avorter
non je crois pas après je crois pas
parce que si la tâche je pense que si on
a su mener avec un jour qu'on aime enfin
avec qui on est bien si on se retrouve
enceinte c'est pas par hasard
je prends je peux me faire matin ça peut
arriver là après je pense que c'est fait
on joue fait détruire toutes les scènes
non c'était juste pour savoir c'était
vrai jules diop s'est bien déroulé
ouais je pense avoir roulé je suis j'ai
fait un très bon pote trop d'histoires
ça va non je crois pas est-ce qui sait
la chance qu'il a d'être avec toi
j'espère non surtout pas ouais ouais
ouais 500 sans forfanterie
ouais c'est en fait on dirait qu'il
s'est donné beaucoup de jus j'ai 19 ans
justement dit je voudrais en appartement
mais en fait j'ai été marqué très tôt
avec très jeune avec un macaque je suis
resté longtemps
donc j'ai pas j'ai pas une nature comme
ça je sais pas d'une sexualité vagabond
de 10 ans il s'appelle actes sexuels en
matière très sexuelle via le pantalon en
cuir il n'y est pas pour rien voilà
c'est ça me dit j'ai les ex
non je suis fan et en même temps c'est
vrai que je suis pas déçu je perds la
gabon ouais mais je pouvais l'être mais
pourquoi pas 7 quel signe du scorpion
moi je pense pas que le sinestro logique
serait grand chose à voir avec l'avenir
mais sur le profil psychologique des
gens ça peut avoir une certaine réalité
ouais ouais c'est que les scores du
sport tas dans le secteur mais je sais
j'espère c'est le signe le plus un matin
sous le signe le plus sexuellement tu
sais ça
[Musique]
ça va te faire avec la ville canton
c'est pas grave alors mister non au
contraire je le contraire un peu ton
grave très grave le contraire que ce qui
peut être des fois tu es des dentelles
des montres linge par 19 à avoir un côté
prix m ouais d'accord ça va trop de
poitrine c'est le seul problème
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok
[Musique]
m
coc
j'ai pas vu des tribunes a pas de soucis
moi je dis un truc et ça sera sur la
place et bien la télé comme c'est super
arrivé vingt ans
deux familles
m
pas en france mais l'on bon enfant perd
en défense
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le père
[Musique]
je suis mort de rire
alan était 6 3
[Musique]
à la
mentez avec
quant à lui
[Musique]
grandvillars
là
dormez dans un oui
wen
[Applaudissements]
b
[Musique]
en
bagnols et alan jones du nautisme
on peut
[Musique]
j'avais l'air
jetons
[Musique]
et
mal
avec le fonds
[Musique]
j'arrête
je ne
2 me
[Musique]
le monde
voir
[Musique]
et
je m'appelle
[Musique]
ces mêmes et son plein
m
le poème
[Musique]
vingt trois
le goût de lait
trouver
un peu moins
graf
m
je suis demandée
tu te sens
[Musique]
je
je n'ai
[Musique]
oui
besson
je
aller vers le bûcher j'en ai assez
d'entendre ce qui se passait
je
cuba
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
si oui
ah ah
et
rien rater levine a l'habitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus